former vice president of the Tokyo
Electric Power Company sake Muto arrives
at court to hear his fate
he's followed in by Ichiro takakuro
another former executive accused of
professional negligence in the Fukushima
nuclear disaster
the Tokyo High Court finds that they
together with former chairman sune Issa
katsumata were not responsible the judge
says they couldn't have foreseen the
size of the tsunami that triggered the
Meltdown of the reactors
outside Court protesters say they're
disappointed by the ruling
I thought they'd be found guilty without
a doubt so I was really not expecting
this verdict it makes me wonder why the
court found them not guilty
foreign most other lawsuits have found
the power company guilty so I can't
understand why the criminal court is the
odd one out
in March 2011 a magnitude 9 earthquake
struck Japan's eastern coast it
triggered a tsunami that sent huge waves
surging as far as 10 kilometers in land
the Fukushima nuclear plant was
overwhelmed and seawater flooded its
reactors the radiation leak forced more
than 150 000 people to flee
the high court decision differs from a
separate ruling in a civil case brought
by shareholders the former Executives
were ordered to pay 95 billion dollars
in compensation in July last year for
failing to prevent the disaster while
this ruling is the end of any criminal
proceedings those affected say they
won't stop fighting for justice
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera